as you know now we're standing strong
with our farmers and ranchers once again
in normal times roughly 40% to fresh
vegetables at about 40% of beef grown
and raised in the United States is
distributed to restaurants and other
commercial food establishments but as
you know the virus has forced many of
our nation's restaurants to temporarily
close and this taken a major toll on our
farmers and growers some of whom we're
dealing directly with restaurants I
didn't realize that until yesterday
we're with the big restaurants and they
sometimes will deal directly with your
farmer no middlemen no nothing just
directly and it's a big it's a big
business for this reason my
administration is launching a sweeping
new initiative the coronavirus food
assistance program through this effort
we are providing 19 billion dollars to
support our nation's agricultural
producers maintain the health of our
critical food supply chains and provide
food assistance to American families 19
billion dollars no other president's
done this hippie I'll tell you you could
go back to Abraham Lincoln there's no
president that's treated the farmers
like Trump no no I hear we're doing well
with the farmers but I can't imagine I
want to find out who wouldn't be who
wouldn't be with Trump right but it's an
honor to do it actually it's an honor
they're great people these are great
great people as part of this program
today we're announcing 16 billion dollar
direct payments to farmers and ranchers
so 16 billion is going directly to the
farmers and ranchers and it's authorized
by the cares Act and the commodity
Credit Corporation Charter Act we fought
hard for this these payments will
compensate farmers for losses related to
the global pandemic caused by China will
be providing billions of dollars for
corn cotton soybean and specialty crop
farmers cattle ranchers just about every
category I think we have almost every
category and if we don't we're gonna add
them all right if we left something
Apple we have a lot of a lot of
territory dairy produces pork producers
and more I read yesterday where we take
some cattle in from other countries
because we have trade deals I think you
should look at terminating those deals
all right we have trade deals where we
actually take in cattle and we have a
lot of cattle in this country and I
think you should look at the possibility
of terminating those trade deals now if
a country has been a great country and a
great ally and a great friend it's you
know you have to do that but there are
some countries that are sending us
cattle for many years and I think we
should look at terminating we're very
self-sufficient and we're becoming more
and more self-sufficient probably one of
the reasons I got elected sign-ups will
begin on May 26 through your local Farm
Service Agency office is it got to go
sign up to pick it up to get the money
and we'll start issuing payments within
one week of receiving your application
so that's a lot of money you're talking
about a total of 16 billion plus 3
billion and you know we bought last week
and it's already in distribution three
billion dollars worth of product for the
Food lines and it's is this already in
distribution I see that they're handing
it out I see where they couldn't get
food they're having a hard time and we
have these incredible ranchers and
farmers that have so much food and I
said let's spend that money and give it
to our farmers our ranchers and it's
worked out really well so and they've
already got it in supply that's it's
already on the lines I saw them handing
it out today a couple of days ago
actually it's fantastic how quickly it
worked
in addition this important initiative
also includes the new farmers to
families Food Box program which Ivanka
and secretary Purdue helped officially
launched on Friday through this effort
the Department of Agriculture will work
with local food distribution companies
and we have a lot of great distribution
companies I've gotten to meet some of
them which have also been hit very hard
to purchase three billion dollars of
food and products from the American
farmer which I just mentioned and to
deliver to the food banks and charities
that serve needy families already we
have allocated one
point two billion dollars to farmers to
families funding through 198 contracts
with distribution companies many of
which are small businesses adversely
impacted also by this horrible plague to
plague here today are a few of the
American farmers and ranchers who can
tell us why this program has been so
essential and successful Scott Cink is a
cattle producers business has been badly
impacted by the virus he says this
initiative will provide a bridge to help
them move forward and we've been helping
them in a lot of other ways too but this
was a great help and Scott please come
forward thank you Scott hi my name is
Scott sink I'm a producer in Southwest
Virginia Blacksburg we have a catering
business that we do farm-to-table along
with raising livestock produce and
custom hay we were able to benefit from
the paycheck protection program and now
this bridge will also help us get into
the new growing season talking to
farmers all across the country you know
farming is something that's always
unexpected we deal with that we have to
pivot at any time but with something
like this that's impacted the supply
chain producers as well as consumers
that's why having a program like this is
very beneficial to all of us so we thank
y'all you wouldn't trade businesses for
anything right what is it with farmers
they don't want to do anything else they
have some bad years but we've helped
them have very good years actually but
they have some bad years but they
wouldn't trade it for anything with it
yeah that's true and then they stopped
making money and they go out and buy
bigger tractors maybe they'll slow it up
a little bit the next time right but you
guys are great Robert Mills raises both
crops and livestock and he believes this
program will help countless farm
families get by and more than by as we
begin to reopen our economy and its
opening up really fast Robert please
come up Robert thank you thank you mr.
president
I'm Robert Mills jr. I'm a first
generation farmer from south side of
Virginia
we raised tobacco beef cattle poultry
hay small grain and industrial hemp for
CBD we're a pretty diverse operation and
we're diverse because we always expect
the unexpected and we want to make sure
that we can stay in business and we
didn't expect this but I will tell the
American people that you're farmers and
you're Ranchers right here working each
and every day to make sure that those
grocery store shelves stay fool and it's
administration's like president Trump's
administration and the forethought that
he's had with the programs that's been
put in place and the one that we're
talking about today it's not a rescue
program it's going to help these farm
families be able to make good wise
financial decisions in the months and
weeks and years ahead and it's also
there to let them know that this country
is there supporting them because this
country relies on what these farmers and
ranchers do every day and so I want to
personally thank President Trump the
administration and all those who've
worked hard to make sure that these farm
families stay there that they stay home
and that the American people will never
have to worry about running out of food
Thank You mr. president
that's great area thank you very much
great job you know the farmers were
targeted by China when we started
negotiating tough with China and what I
did is we've taken in tens of billions
of dollars of tariffs Sonny was very
aware of this because he had to
distribute the money to the farmers I
said Sonny we've taken in a lot of money
how much did the farmers lose this is
two years ago they were targeted for an
amount what do you think the impact he
said twelve billion dollars so I said
that's okay we'll take 12 billion
dollars out of our tariff money which
was many billions more than that that
China paid never paid us $0.10 by the
way before that before Trump they never
paid anything I said we'll take 12
billion out of the tens of billions of
dollars that we took in and we're going
to give it to the farmers and you
distributed that money
and zippy I think you were shocked
because you've never seen anything like
otherwise these farmers wouldn't have
been in business so we took 12 million
we gave it to the farmers we said thank
you very much to China
thank you very much China and then the
next year said sunny what's the number
we call zippy we called some of the
other people we determined it was 16
billion dollars that the farmers were
targeted 16 billion by China so I took
16 billion out of the tariffs which were
many many billions of tens of billions
more than that we gave it to the farmers
right and this year the same thing it's
been pretty amazing and the farmers are
doing fine one of them said I'd do
better this way but you know what they
don't want to do better that way they
just want a level playing field but we
took care of our farmers right and
ranchers thank you Robert that was great
appreciate it David Hickman is a
vegetable grower who runs Dublin farms
in Virginia's potatoes will be among the
produce distributed to local food banks
through the farmers to families program
and David please come up and say a few
words hi David
I'm David Hicks moon Dublin farms in
horn town Virginia we are fifth
generation operation produce Fresh
Market potatoes red skins yellows whites
this program is going to help
tremendously with the movement of
potatoes this summer for us we have six
distributors who are our current
customers that are doing the Food Box
program so our potatoes will be in some
of these food boxes we've submitted bids
for five pound bags to go directly to
the food banks of yellow and white
potatoes certainly going to impact the
Virginia potato business cf five-pound
bags what are those sized bags we do we
have a packing operation we pack five
pound bags ten pound bags
50-pound bag
and then 2,000 pound bags go to other
Packers but a lot of our business goes
into the terminal markets also that's
dependent on restaurant business so
we're anxious to see our restaurants get
back up certain sizes the potatoes are
used primarily for foodservice so it's a
potato a big business in Virginia
it's a regionally it's a big business in
our area called Eastern Shore we're very
very very small compared to the i/o
production but we fit a niche between
for the North Carolina spring production
because it or a similar product was a
different know the Idaho potatoes are
like the russet long potato we grow red
skin potatoes and round yellow potatoes
we do but we we feel a different market
that's very good our potato just
interesting yeah our potato chip right
from the field to the store that's where
I go they storm through the winter and
we also go grow green beans for Fresh
Market which is largely dependent on
restaurant business also grow corn
soybeans for the culture is bang on all
my life yes sir on my home farm there's
been potatoes playing her there since
1887 which is sort of unusual in the
country all different parts of that
field has been farmed it's being
potatoes too sometimes you know we
appreciate what you're doing well thank
you very much I guess you quit you gave
me a little education potatoes that's
wonderful I mind I'll be there
we're going after Virginia with your
crazy governor we're going after
Virginia they want to take your second
amendment the way you know that right
you have nobody guarding your potatoes
as each of you demonstrate a healthy
economy is vital to maintaining a
healthy society and by working together
we could restore our economy shield the
vulnerable care for the needy deliver
world-class health care and vanquish the
virus and I have to say this the job you
do is so powerful and so important the
American
is very critical to the success of that
mission and what I'd like to do is just
before I finish I'd like to ask zippy to
come up and say a couple of words
because he really is at the forefront of
so much of what we do so zippy Duvall
come on up Thank You mr. president
I remember for four years and several
months ago I won the election to be
President American Farm Bureau and
candidate Trump called me and he says
I'm gonna be a friend to the farmer mr.
president I'm here at a two-day thank
you you've lived up to those words that
you made to me that day I represent all
farmers across the country
I also farm my son and I I'm third
generation my son's fourth generation we
run a 400 cow beef cattle operation and
we grow chickens for Pihl comprise about
a median half chickens a year and and
the farmers across America are very
appreciative mr. president what you've
done you've stood behind us during a
trade war you did stood behind us during
all the difficulties we went through and
now with the pandemic you stood behind
us again and you know and you've made
the comment we're the only group comes
to the White House without our hand we
don't come to the hands out we want that
level playing field we want that trade
we won't be able to make our money from
from the markets and but we appreciate
when we're going through difficult times
that you stand behind us this pandemics
made us realize one thing we live in
land of plenty but there's a food chain
that is just as important to us as our
military is we have to be able to feed
our own people we can't afford to be fed
by other countries that makes us a
national security issue and we know that
you realize that and I think the
American people unfortunately have had
go to the store and see some empty
shells and we all now realize how
important that chain that food chain is
in the farmer is that very first link
without that support we wouldn't be
there to produce that food our farmers
are still farming hashtag still farm and
you've got some great stories we've
touched over 50 men
in people was that hashtag talking about
what farmers are doing still farming but
we want to thank you we won't think
secretary Purdue for his hard work his
staffs done an excellent job putting
this problem together and we won't thank
Congress for thinking about agriculture
to and delivering it to your desk for
you to sign so many thanks for helping
the people that feed the American people
and we look forward to continuing to
work with you mr. Trump we appreciate
thank you that's two four and a half
years ago I called zippy never spoke to
him and he liked me I liked him and I
don't know
I got good support right from the
beginning but we've come through we've
come absolute she's a great woman great
woman thank you very much zippy so just
to conclude American farmers ranchers
and growers feed fuel and sustain our
nation they're proud defenders of the
American Way of life and I'm proud to
stand right by their side in this hour
of need and the food chains are now back
to almost working perfectly again they
had some interruptions which you knew
about and we were able to take a very
bold action you saw that and that action
caused them to do what they had do and
they were in good shape and very shortly
there'll be an absolutely perfect shape
but people were worried about that the
action we took was a very important
action Larry Kudlow wasn't it we did a
good job now I'd like to ask secretary
Purdue to say a few words followed by
Ivanka and Marty Smith if I could okay
please very clearly you calling me just
a few weeks ago when you read about the
effects of the pandemic on American
agriculture and once again you directed
me sunny we're going to help our farmers
bring me a program what's it going to
take I want you to use all the available
resources at your disposal just as
you've done before when China retaliated
against our farmers there I don't know
how mr. president but you instinctively
know that American agriculture farmers
and ranchers have been the bedrock of
our American economy since the founding
of our nation
and I still are and we talked about the
food supply chain you know that
instinctively but I've I want to tell
you I've never in my lifetime seen
another president recognize that value
among the folks standing here and
they're representing farmers and
ranchers all across the country so we're
very appreciative at USDA that we don't
have to push the rock up the hill
usually when it comes to President Trump
the rocks coming down the hill have to
catch it
so we and we appreciate that very much
that we don't have to sell you on the
value of Agriculture but the program
that we're announcing today will be a
benefit the 16 million dollars of direct
farmer direct payments to farmers of all
sizes and all really all production
there will be very helpful a real
lifeline but certainly the program that
evoke and I were privileged to go out
last Friday to coastal produce that you
see here is also a lifeline not only
those specialty crop producers both
dairy producers and meat producers but
also to the families who need this food
there you can see this is high quality
food here that's being distributed all
across the country to our food banks and
really a lifeline for them as well so
the food supply chain that begins with
these producers representing farmers and
ranchers all across the country ending
up in the families tables that need this
food is a real noble profession I'm
honored to be a part of it and I'm
really particularly honored president
Trump that you understand just in your
heart how valuable our American
agricultural sector is and I thank you
Thank You secretary this is an
incredibly exciting day as this very
large relief package is is announced and
you can hear today and you can hear
through the course of the campaign in
the last three years the special place
all of you have in the heart of this
president farmers and ranchers feed
America and that's never been more true
than we've all realized over the course
of the last several months in addition
to the much-needed relief the 16 billion
dollars will go to farmers and ranchers
to to help support them through this
difficult time this farmers to family
food
box program is just an amazing
initiative as the secretary mentioned
the president saw that there were those
in need those vulnerable long lines at
food banks trying to get food and yet
there was this unbelievable beautiful
American fresh produce that was going to
waste so thinking about that supply
chain and ensuring with three billion
dollars that those who are vulnerable
that those who are need get access to
boxes like these twenty to twenty-five
pounds of meat milk all forms of dairy
and and of course great fresh produce is
is incredibly virtuous it's a great
cycle it helps the small distributors it
helps the small farmers who were
prioritized in in the bids and of course
it helps those in need so we're very
excited about this program these boxes
themselves will also be going to a
mission here in DC along with several
others that we have at the White House
and we hope that these boxes will play a
big role in in feeding those who need it
across the country so so thank you and
thank you secretary for the hard work of
your team in standing up this program so
rapidly we think that it will be
extraordinarily successful for our small
farmers and and of course those in need
so thank you
Thank You mr. president you have
provided unprecedented leadership and to
the United States and to the world
throughout this crisis and with that you
have shown so much concern and so much
support for American agriculture and on
behalf of the National Cattlemen's Beef
Association and the rest of Agriculture
let's say thank you
I'm Marty Smith and I'm a rancher from
Florida and serving this year as
president of the National Cattlemen's
Beef Association your executive order a
few weeks ago directed toward the
Packers we're starting to see the impact
of that we're getting beef back online
and getting the products back on the
shelf you know America's farmers and
ranchers continue to work around the
clock to feed the public to feed all of
our nation feed a lot part of the large
part of the world what you've done with
that and what we're doing with this with
this current program enables us to stay
in business and continue to do that
again we thank you for that we thank
your administration working with
secretary Purdue has just been a great
way Forrestal moving forward but even
more importantly that I want to thank
you and your family you know with us
it's all about our families and our
family operation your family is just as
dedicated to this and Ivanka we thank
you for the support you've shown to us
it's just it's so meaningful and
together we get through this and we do
beat this and we keep the highest
quality safest most sustainable protein
sources on the plate of Americans all
through this and we thank you thank you
mr. president maybe with will any of
this aid he directed towards cattleman
chicken farmers and pork producers who
had to euthanize their flocks already
because of you oh yes for gathering that
data now this particular direct payment
is not directly for that there will be
help coming through NRCS over the
euthanasia and disposal coming that way
so there will be certainly directed
there soon it'll be after this is
announced and we get more data we are
still there are a lot of rumors out
there about what's actually happening we
want to get the facts my data and make
policy based on good how is your
administration addressing the
comorbidities that secretary a czar that
are responsible for a lot of the
coronavirus of deaths obesity
hypertension diabetes obviously very
closely connected to our food supply
well I think we just want people in this
country to be healthy how does every
country address it we want our people to
be healthy we want them to be happy and
we want them to have all of the benefits
that you could have including great
health care the Republican Party's been
very strong on health care as you know
and that includes pre-existing
conditions
and we have done a terrific job on
health care then we got hit by a plague
like nobody's ever seen before outside
of maybe 1917 and I think we've done an
incredible job in producing ventilators
and producing testing right now you
probably saw the numbers were over 12
million tests that's three times more
four times more than any other country
in the world and we're talking about
countries that have done a good job
nobody's done testing like us plus we
have the highest quality test so very
simply we want our people to be healthy
how are you addressing those
specifically your own call the Human
Services Secretary said that's why
America has so many pretty taxes do
whatever people make food and that's one
of the reasons we have our farmers and
ranchers it was probably you say it's a
problem with importing Canada weather
well we take 8 it's a relatively small
number actually I heard sunny speaking
about it yesterday it's a very small
number but it's still cattle coming and
we have tremendous amounts of supply
cattle and you know all but generally
speaking supply tremendous supply our
farmers have done an incredible job and
now the distribution is being made much
better than it has been and better I
think it'll end up being much better
than it's ever been
zippy but I'm saying why are we bringing
in cattle all trade deals that were made
a long time ago why are we bringing in
cattle from other countries where we
have so much ourselves now in some cases
I thought your answer was very good
they've been great allies they've been
working with us for many years sometimes
we needed the cattle and sometimes we
don't it's a farming business but I
would say generally speaking unless this
is a country that really has been with
us we shouldn't be thinking they can you
know that okay and that's the way we're
gonna happen on a separate subject you
sent a letter last night to the deputy
what reforms do they need to do to know
the system understand I don't want to go
through it the letters a very detailed
long letter but basically they have to
clean up their act they have to do a
better job they have to be much more
fair to other countries including the
United States so we're not going to be
involved with them anymore we'll do it a
separate way
still concerned about their safety and
that they want
let's do more to import to make sure
that attachment companies are keeping
their that their workers safe with
protected
testing etc is there any more that you
plan to do to make sure and enforce that
mean company in there I've been very
much involved with plants since this
problem came up and what we've done
they've done a lot in terms of shields
and other things but they have a they
had a disproportionately high number of
people that had the problem and that's
going away the plants are very very
clean now and they're getting to a level
where I think we had some a report that
they cleaner than they've ever been
that's a good report but I don't know
exactly what that means but they are
cleaner than they've ever been
they're doing a very good job I think
right now in terms of the production act
and in terms of what we're enforcing but
the meatpacking plants are coming online
many of them are online and fewer and
fewer problems of being seen if we
didn't act we would had a big problem if
somebody was in this position that
didn't act we would add a big problem
but it's something that we were very
much involved in because we saw it very
early okay yes you extending the
us-canada we're dealing with the Prime
Minister's friend of ours and we're very
close to Canada we decide the u.s. MCA
which is a big deal and it's with Mexico
and with Canada and we're dealing on
that subject and we're also on the
southern border as you know the wall is
going up it's going up very rapidly
we're at 182 miles wherever we have the
wall it's just ended it just ended
people coming into our country illegally
with stopping drug traffic was stopping
the trafficking and people mostly women
because they trafficked mostly women
unfortunately it's a tremendously big
business it's a horrible business and
we're stopping it is a worldwide problem
this isn't a problem for our southern
border but our southern border is a big
point and we're stopping trafficking the
wall has had an incredible power and
strength on what we're doing I have to
say this so we'll have by pretty early
next year we'll have 450 to 500 miles of
wool fully built so we're doing a great
job on the border we have among the
lowest numbers we've ever had of people
coming in and we're moving them out as
soon as they come in as they come in
we're moving them out literally we're
moving on that immediately
and that's never taken place before
meaning in the last in modern history
it's never taken out
trade are you going to extend the ban
that you've put in place on
non-essential
before now yes but we're talking to
Canada as things clean up in terms of
the plague we're both gonna want to do
the normal we want to get back
everything we want to get back to normal
I think we're gonna have a fantastic
year next year I think we will do very
well in the fourth quarter and I think
the transition quarter which is coming
up we're starting it very shortly the
third quarter I think you'll see some
very good numbers but you're gonna see
some great numbers in the fourth quarter
and you can end up doing a great gear
next year you can see it look at the
states that are opening up they're busy
and their numbers interesting lis going
down so they're opening up you look at
Florida and Georgia in particular the
numbers are going down so we're very
we're very confident that we're going to
have a tremendous tremendous turnaround
and we had to turn it off artificially
and now we're turning it back on and
you're going to see some tremendous
numbers thank you very much everything
about the capital but then you give your
finger Republican senators not based
immediately
for CNN affiliate